Sensei Maila Participation Nowhere
[music]
naruho Please go through Ah,
the phenomenon of drowning has existed in the past.
I breathed into my lungs prematurely In other
words, the water I take in through my mouth doesn't escape from my gills, but
accumulates in my lungs.
In other words, secure a passage for the water
[music]
However, the meeting should be breathing off
[music], me [music]
Mmm,
surfing As
expected, it's tough for two people to pull up together.
I'm jumping in without you,
so please put yourself in this position 5 people
I'll ask about the seats later I wonder if I've saved a good color or something I'm blue but how
long will the
sound be embracing each other?
It has nothing to do with this if you worry about selling
[music]